[Music]
if controlled backwards time travel was
possible today where do you think your
matter or information would travel and
no I'm not talking about what time do
you want to travel though the answers
are but rather if you were in a third
position third person position observing
someone traveled back in time what do
you think is would look like so the time
travel itself if you were the Observer
what would you see if you were able to
observe the timeline itself so I like
that but also just slipped in there
Brian was some mention about information
yes and and that links to entropy I
presume so if you can tackle both of
those in the next 90 seconds before yeah
so so look I think the only the only
real way to answer that question is to
commit to a version of time travel to
the past and the version that I find
most convincing involves
wormholes and the idea of a wormhole I
think many people know this idea it's a
tunnel from one location in space to
another location pays a kind of shortcut
and if you move those openings relative
to each other or you put one near a
black hole again there'll be a time
difference between the two openings so
now one opening is ahead one opening is
behind so you go through the tunnel One
Direction you go to the Future you go
through the tunnel the other direction
you go to the past so what would going
to the Past look like somebody would
enter the opening of a wormhole and they
would disappear and they pop out the
other opening of the Wormhole at a
different place at a different time and
so in the Marvel in the Marvel Universe
where you have Doctor Strange opening
these portals he's only moving through
space he's not actually moving through
time so that's a that's a lost
storytelling element there that they
could totally do interesting things with
it seems to me yeah yeah I mean the
richness of wormholes really arises when
you have a time difference between the
two openings I mean it's fun to have a
tunnel through space but it is
mind-blowing to have a tunnel through
time yeah and also I would add that I
think I can add correctly Brian that as
portrayed in the movie uh contact where
jod Foster goes through this we presume
is a wormhole to get to to visit the
aliens and then she returns we like the
idea that it's like a water slide you
know you're in this tunel you're in this
tube and you're you're sliding and there
but it's really just a simple hole you
step through it right it's not some
Journey isn't that correct because
they're in they're they're basically in
the same place uh they can be but you
can also have situations where the
throat of the Wormhole has some length
to it and then again it would just be
traveling through space it wouldn't be
some kind of like you say water slide or
some kind of weird thing that was
happening but uh but you're right okay
so all right so if you're going to do
this at least and report on it you if
you're in a wormhole and it's propped up
nicely and it's safe for you then you
you're just moving through space
backwards in time if the opening of that
Wormhole is near a black hole where time
is ticking more slowly than where you
came from or if it was there for a while
once you set the time difference between
two openings you can then move away from
the black hole because the time
difference will then
persist wow
Jesus oh yeah so what a wormhole enables
by the way if you manage to travel
someplace faster than light you have the
capacity to move backwards in time
that's we've got that one established as
well we just don't have any easy way to
travel faster than light but one one way
that's been celebrated in science
fiction and you can write it out on
paper legitimately is a wormhole a
wormhole I'm over here and I want to get
over there and I want to get there
quickly I want to get there before the
end of the commercial break okay so you
can travel through a wormhole that
changes the effective distance between
where you are and where you're going and
then you sort
of look around when you get there and
you find oh my gosh I've traveled
100,000 light years in a matter of a
moment okay when you do that you have
the capacity to move backwards in time
relative to when you left now you don't
get to visit yourself you're in a sort
of a different uh SpaceTime trajectory
so you can't shake hands with yourself
before you left that so if that's what
you're thinking of doing no and by the
way there's a huge there's a huge
Paradox that people worry about and and
many people including Stephen Hawking
the late Stephen Hawking worried whether
this paradox would
prevent backwards time travel completely
because if you go back in time and
prevent your parents from meeting one
another then they wouldn't have ever
given birth to you to go back in time to
prevent them from meeting one another
first of all let me just say I stopped
listening when you said I can't shake
hands with
[Laughter]
myself so if there were a rule book of
time travel
um the number
one
item would be you cannot go back in time
and prevent your parents from meeting
each
other because then you would have never
been born to have gone back in time to
have prevented your parents from meeting
each other this is the fundamental
Paradox of time travel and so that if
there were a rule book that'd be number
one rule so here's the thing so yes you
wouldn't have a Terminator movie if the
terminator's sole job was to prevent
Sarah Connor from becoming
pregnant okay that's a different movie
from killing systematically every Sarah
Connor in the phone book right so and he
wouldn't have to do that he could go one
generation earlier and prevent the
grandparents from eating or prevent the
great-grandparents from eating or the
Great great great parents mean anywhere
in that genetic chain if you disrupt it
then you are not born and so could
introduced the great great grandmother
to a much better looking
guy and you just have a better looking
time traveler going there go like I'm
considered Michael B
Jordan he's very
attractive
that's a different Terminator movie
right
exactly so so I'm just saying these
people think they're on some locktite
theme when the theme is way broader than
that in fact uh forgive me for not
remembering which movie this was it'll
come to me in a moment where they
realized that if two
people if if two people had sex 10
minutes later
than they otherwise did then a different
sperm fertilizes likely the same egg and
that's but it's nonetheless a completely
different person wow so even if you
don't disrupt the sex just delay it make
the train come a little later make the
you know uh have the the cup of coffee
be extra delicious so they get a second
cup before they or or the wine whatever
is the Romantic forces operating that
evening or just make sure they have
other kids cuz that will stop you from
ever being able to do it
again five other kids running around
house all you got to do you know it's
just like I mean that's what I found out
during the pandemic you know you you in
the house you be L man we've been here
for a while what are we going to
do every time you try to disappear they
show right up knocking on the door what
are you guys doing what's going on in
there okay so that's a time traveling
movie Never Never conceived see what I
did there very ni see what you did there
it's you trying to prevent the parents
from having sex they're not having not
having it anyway that's it because they
got five kids running up and down
bouncing off the walls got the other
kids just like no in popular pars it's
called the grandfather Paradox but it's
a paradox to any one of your ancestry
because disrupting that chain will
prevent you from being born someone else
could be born now now you can you can
get you can introduce a more interesting
idea that
maybe the forces of the
timeline care about major
events even in spite of you changing
minor events that'd be an interesting
fact right I I I I don't really agree
with that idea but it' be an interesting
sci-fi so is that kind of like
inevitability so it's like even you
change these minor things the inevitable
will still happen correct so it could be
that you know you killed the the some
ancestor of yours so you don't
exist but somebody else arises in the
life of the other partner because you
just have to kill one of the partners
right that creates some other person who
basically does exactly what you were
going to do in your life right so so
it's not you but the larger scale events
still unfold and my favorite example of
this which involves no killing at all is
if you could communicate backwards
through time we have a hypothetical
particle that does that you know what
it's called you ever hear no it's called
the tachon oh tachon okay tachon and
it's I think it's from the Greek tacos
meaning fast tachometer that's the same
route a tachometer which gives you the
the the the speed of your engine uh if
you still have an engine car yeah yeah
the RPMs that's a tachometer so we have
this hypothetical part it's never been
observed but we sort of introduce it
it's called a
tachon it exists moving faster than the
speed of light and as you may remember
Chuck as you go faster and faster and
faster your time slows down relative to
everybody else right at the speed of
light time stops but what happens if you
cross the speed of light then time goes
backwards according to the equations so
we are imagining if you could ever
accomplish this time would go backwards
for you so we introduced this particle
it's called tach on so now you have a
tachon texting smartphone okay and your
buddy's walking down the
corridor and you see your buddy slip on
a banana peel and fall and you say I
don't want my buddy to slip on a banana
peel and fall so you pull out your tach
on text message service and you say
watch out for the banana peel you send
it to them after this event has already
happened but they receive the text
before it happens right okay you got
this because it moved backwards in time
right okay so then what happens is
they're walking down the
corridor and then the text
alert happens okay so they pull out
their smartphone and start reading the
smartphone and it says watch out for the
banana peel but the very fact of having
pulled out the smartphone and looked at
it meant they weren't looking down in
that moment and they slip on the banana
peel and they slip on the peel so you
caused the very event that you thought
that you were avoid uh preventing
correct
correct um let's start out with with
Looper so let me just give the plot line
you are an assassin who kills bad guys
who was sent into the past thereby
disappearing from the future and then
you kill them and dispose of their body
so they're basically wiped off the face
of the Earth as anyone in the future
would know or concern and then you
confront yourself as someone you're
supposed to kill brilliantly played by
Bruce Willis and then there's an issue
there about whether you kill your future
self or not and that's all I'll say
about in case anyone hasn't seen it but
my point is is you have an encounter
with your future self and this seems to
break some some time travel uh rules I'm
I'm thinking to myself are there time
travel rules though
I'm you got
me Joe I thought I could pass that
through you but I
couldn't no but I'm actually I'm curious
to ask you cuz I'm a fan of time travel
movies so you know like I mentioned Back
to the Future or you know what want to
talk about Quantum Leap I was in an
episode of Quantum Leap when I was 10
years old the
old um but time wait a minute wait wait
wait and weren't you forgive me I
weren't you in in Third Rock yeah yeah
yeah oh my God this that's right
speaking of a cosmic perspective right
you were a kid third walk from the Sun
with oh just just remember that right
it's not in my notes here so I I I just
remembered that so you've been at this
for a while oh I've been doing this a
long time feeling good about this okay
so so uh I don't know if there's a rule
we'll have to ask some of our time
travel would would that kind of thing be
possible I mean is there any any
indication in any serious science to say
that a human could travel from one place
on the time continuum and end up in a
different place intact with their same
human body and brain and yeah I think
there's not that itself is not the
problem the the problem comes about with
as they say the grandfather Paradox
right where you go back and you prevent
your grandfather from meeting your
grandmother or in a Terminator version
of that you kill your grandfather so
that you're never born to be sent back
in time yeah to meet your grandfather
okay or or some so there's a paradoxical
Loop problem yes that uh that Steph
Hawking thinks there was not there is no
solution to it at all that we will
discover a new time travel conjecture
that will prevent backwards time travel
in that way and there a couple of
scenarios and there's another one wait
when you say a conjecture you mean that
there'll be some kind of evidence or
kind of mathematically
backed uh statement that says this is
actually impossible it'll never happen
Stephen Hawking believed that we would
one day derive either mathematically or
experimentally that conjecture just so
as to prevent the grand father Paradox
from unfolding right and so but what was
what's what intrigues me in loer you met
your future self 30 years hence yes and
and had conversations with that person
and that's just I don't I don't know if
that's allowed that's all I'm saying
yeah and I don't know what to say yeah I
mean I think it's definitely not allowed
and look at that we did it anyway okay
we got no but I mean there's there there
was actually there was a scene there's a
great scene one of my favorite scenes in
the movie where my character and Bruce
Willis's character who like you're
saying are supposed to be the same man
just younger and older version of the
same man they sit down at a diner
together and talk and there was a
version of the script where the older
man explains some of the mechanics of
the time travel oh
probably in a you know in in terms that
Stephen Hawking would deem serious but
at least in terms that felt necessary to
the story in that draft of the
script but later Ryan in what I think is
a wise move decided to cut all of that
out and there's just a line now where
Bruce Willis kind of gets prickly and
angry and says we're not going to talk
about time travel oh okay
so all right so you leave it more to us
to try to think about
it you don't want to have loops in space
and time in which you can't have cause
and effect be logically consistent right
so we're all used to things in the past
affecting things in the future but if
time loops around then the future
actually can affect the past so the
danger in ether and one of the
Diagnostics we use to see if e theory is
healthy is to make sure it doesn't have
any of these closed Tim likee Curves in
which cause and effect would be muddled
up by the structure of SpaceTime this is
a philosophical bias you are
implementing on the universe itself it's
a little bit more than philosophical
because you want the unfolding of events
to be internally consistent you're
saying you want something to be true in
the universe that sounds like you're
begging for let me just say God needs it
to be that way right because if the laws
of physics yield inconsistent results
then everything falls apart everything
no we just live in an inconsistent
Universe problem with that no no what it
means is our understanding is messed up
clearly the world makes sense no I used
to believe that I take it back now do
you think one day we'll have a machine
that'll just send us forward in time we
know it's possible but why don't why
aren't we doing it active well I think
we do have a machine in principle right
we just can't go very far forward in
time because every time you go into a
vehicle and you undertake a round trip
Journey you are traveling into the
future by some calculable amount yeah
now at ordinary speeds you're only going
you know a billionth of a billionth of a
second or something like that into the
future into the future but if you found
yourself in a ship that was going near
the speed of light you go out for 6
months you turn around you come back for
six months you get off that ship you
will have aged one year but depending on
how close to the speed of light you got
when you step off the ship Earth will be
10,000 years or a million years into the
future you will have jumped into Earth's
future and that is what we mean by time
travel the faster you go to the speed of
light the slower time moves correct so
somebody on a spaceship would age slower
than somebody on Earth they'd come back
one year later and the people on earth
have aged 10 years 100 years something
like that that's the basic idea that's
the idea and and let me add just to
close out this segment our GPS
satellites orbit high enough so that
there's a measurable and important
difference in its rate of time that it
keeps compared to us here on the surface
of the Earth they're farther away from
the source of gravity Earth so their
time ticks faster than our clock time on
the surface and we know this it's
Einstein's general theory of relativity
so they calculated how much faster their
clocks would tick and they back correct
for that before it sends us the time
that ends up on our
[Music]
smartphones oh yeah so this this one
this next one is from uh Google Plus
like even better I never met Google Plus
even better than Google just a little
bit better so Mr plus ask a little more
charged a little more charged um this
question comes from Frasier Kane of the
website Universe today and it's a
question I've also wondered many times
doesn't the fact that there are no time
travelers now prove that time travel
will never be invented in the
future yeah that's an excellent point
and I've always thought about that
because I said to myself in fact if you
watch the TV the CBS sitcom The Big Bang
Theory uh in the roommate contract
of I know you got to be totally
uh in the roommate contract that
stipulated that
if if I'm getting the details of it
wrong the sense of it is right if
they'll still be very excited if any one
of them invents a time machine in the
future they have to go back to that
moment that they're reading that phrase
in the roommate contract to show up in
the room and so so they're going through
the
contract and then they pause for a
moment no okay we have you know you're
not the one who invents the time machine
in the future that's the ultimate like
let agree to me back here 10 years from
now but it's at the same time it's
awesome exactly and so I think that's a
that's a pretty good argument and I
don't have a rebuttal to that but know
what if people are hiding it what if
people have come back but are not
telling people for some reason because
they don't want to give something away
there's a quote I think it was from R
doll but others perhaps have said it
that the only secret that can be kept
between two people is when one of them
is
dead so I'm pretty sure that if a Time
were out there people would have figured
that one out it's been rumored that the
the reason why the Titanic sank is
because in the future they invented a
time machine and everyone wanted to go
back to the Titanic to see the iceberg
when it hits and then it overloaded the
Titanic and it sank right oh well now
I'm convinced so there's the evidence
you're looking for evidence go that's
hard hardcore evidence so uh that's a
pretty good one yeah and it may it might
be that your time travel machine can
only take you into the future and then
you don't have these paradoxes of
killing your grandmother and then you're
never born to go back to the future
stuff yeah yeah exactly because there's
a movie too coming out called Looper or
Loopers that with Joseph Gordon L and
Bruce Willis and he goes back in time
he's like an assassin that goes back in
time and he goes back and he's scheduled
to kill himself so he has to like figure
out what to do about it you know what's
interesting all these TV shows they have
people going back and killing people all
you have to do but all you have to do is
pick a time where two of your ancestors
who mated produced one of your ancestors
and all you have to do is prevent them
from mating you don't have to kill
anybody just just just your great great
great great great grandparents prevent
him from meeting you would have never
been born that's
all in interstellar they had Matthew
mccon interacting with his timeline so
the premise was you go into a black hole
and you have access to these higher
Dimensions but starting back in ordinary
life we have three dimensions that we're
familiar with on a grid you might think
of it as what street in New York what
street what Avenue and what floor in a
building that you might meet someone
these are three coordinates that you
would give remember however that anytime
you've ever made an appointment to see
someone not give a time without a place
nor would you give a place without a
time so the actual coordinates to meet
someone require four numbers basically
four coordinates three space coordinates
and one time coordinate you never said
to your friend I'll meet you at 10:00
tomorrow
where you never say I'll meet you at the
corner 33rd and
third
when we know intuitively that we need a
space and a Time coordinate combined in
order to have life unfold in any
meaningful way so the idea that we live
in four dimensions should not be
surprising to people we take it for
granted actually actually but the
difference is that we are not prisoners
of our three-dimensional space I can
walk left and right I can jump up and
down I can walk forwards and backwards
and I can repeat that I can access all
points of my three-dimensional space yet
I am a
prisoner in the
present forever transitioning from the
past into the future I have no access to
the past I have no access to the
Future and so
if you go to a higher Dimension it's not
unrealistic to think that you step out
of the time
Dimension and now you look at time as
though we look at space so very
questions that we have very statements
that we make about our lives make no
sense in that higher coordinate
system you can ask when was I born well
you always born when did I go to college
you're always going to college when did
I die you're you're always dying and so
if your whole timeline is laid out in
front of you then you have access to it
and you can jump in at any point relive
it uh we don't know yet if you can
interfere with events that quote have
already happened if your whole timeline
is just already there what does it mean
to jump into it and then change
something if it's already there so these
are fascinating questions that make
great fodder for science fiction stories
and we don't know what's in a black hole
so take it and run with it
[Music]